foreign
's intelligence Services put pressure on
Masa amini's family and warned people
not to gather at her grave today
the protesters didn't listen
[Music]
after they left the cemetery police
fired tear gas and shotguns at the
protesters inside Masa amini's home City
but Iranians have been defying the
security forces for 40 days now and they
were not going to stop today
there were protests across Iran too this
was in the capital Tehran
[Applause]
Masa amini's killing anger degeneration
who've had enough of Iran's repressive
and often violent government
now
now they started the protest and then
the men are followed by the men and
their self-working Mariam is a student
in Tehran she hasn't worn her head scarf
for a month in protest and says she
won't wear it again she asked us to
protect her identity we want an
and after about the scarf anymore we
want our freedom so this is about ending
the regime
and yes
but I think uh
what is going on is far beyond my uh
feeling about getting arrested and you
know uh the thing that might happen to
me so this is it this is the beginning
of the end for the
Islamic government yes this is the
beginning event
at the moment neither side is winning
nor is either side backing down
but the longer that this goes on the
more the pressure grows on the Iranian
government to make concessions or take
decisive action
Alistair bunkel Sky News in Northern
Iraq